Yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's okay mechanism
What's
up, it's
dirty, but it's
sewn big It's no good to sew through the smell of midwinter from the whole house Ah, let's go home
Nice to meet you
2 I
can't
go up
I'll leave it in the pudding pudding Don't go home because I'll put it in the fridge I'll go home, thank you, it'll be a hindrance, sleep
.
The
next one is
different, but I want to make it
[Music] I
wonder if I'm always thinking about the next one
. The midwinter when yesterday's song broke down was amazing.
I didn't want to hear that much midwinter love song.  Even I
'm overwhelmed
I wonder where in this slender body I've packed so much loneliness
I want to be next